jason mamoa unharmed after facing a
head-on collision with a motorcycle on
sunday the actor was driving his 1970
oldsmobile in la when a motorcyclist
going the opposite direction crossed
over the double yellow lines crashing
directly into jason's car the california
highway patrol confirms the collision
caused the motorcyclist to be ejected
from his seat he was ultimately
transferred to northridge hospital with
minor non-life-threatening injuries
according to the accident report jason
got out of his car moments after the
crash to help the other driver he also
flagged down another car to call 9-1-1
jason appeared to have no injuries and
remained on the scene as officers
responded and no arrests were made now
the vintage vehicle jason was driving
well it's not the first time fans have
seen him take it for a spin the
oldsmobile 442 was first seen in his
2021 netflix movie sweet girl
there's nowhere to hide
we know who you are
and turns out the film's production
designer shared the actor had quite a
big say in getting the car in the action
thriller
we were looking for a 442 jason said
that's the car he wanted
he's a car guy so he had a lot of input
with the car we looked locally first and
then showed him examples he didn't like
ended up that the best available 442 in
the country was beautifully restored you
know i love cars too so it was very hard
for me to age it and turn it into a rust
bucket jason helped me through that
and if he really wanted to turn it back
to that car the paint will come off
how beautiful that thing is
beautiful piece
it was a really a combined drive we all
had to be this this one moving force and
hats off to everyone that made it
possible
meanwhile jason is set to reprise his
superhero role as aquaman
[Music]
i'm just i'm really stoked at the fan
base and what we did with the movie and
just went into warner brothers in dc and
kind of
said you know i have some ideas and
they love they love them and james and
everyone's just kind of like we're all
taking it in we're excited to do another
one since word first got out about the
film sequel jason's remained very
tight-lipped what can you tell me about
the aquaman sequel
i ain't saying none i'm gonna get in
trouble on that one
how far along in the aquaman two process
are we i'm done i just had surgery yeah
we're done that thing's done the next
aquaman installment is slated to hit
theaters next year and while jason won't
spill a thing we know it's sure to make
a splash i think there's a lot more in
store on a lot there's so many more
levels so your brother's still locked up
just give me a lot it's gonna be a lot
way bigger
[Music]
you